[Music]
this week on fyi two years on from the
worldwide black lives matter protest we
investigate why racism is still a
problem
and do you understand british sign
language us neither not enough people do
but we report on a new app that could
change all that
[Music]
this is fyi where we investigate the big
stories to bring you your fixer weekly
news
yeah and you can't have missed how the
eurovision song contest has been hitting
the headlines if you don't know what
eurovision is all about it's a mega
singing competition where loads of
countries mainly in europe compete for
the best song russia was disqualified
from competing this year weren't they
because of the war in ukraine yeah they
were and ukraine here were the favorites
to win and they did after huge support
from the public vote ukraine was
represented by kalash orchestra who were
given special permission to leave the
country to perform because all men are
supposed to stay in ukraine to support
the war effort one band member did stay
behind them ukrainians everywhere were
so happy that they won i think it's fair
to say that this is much more about
sending out a message that they are very
much part of europe and supported by
europe than just having the best song we
really wanted to know how ukrainians
felt about the result we got a message
from evelina who's staying here in the
uk with the british family after fleeing
the war
high fbi i think it's very cool to see
ukraine win and we can see how many
countries and people support ukraine we
feel like we're part of europe not in
russian and it's very important to
ukraine people when they see ukraine win
we're all very happy and this ukraine
group i say from my town so it's a
very cool and i'm happy to see results
in provisioning in this year
so it's all what i want to say you thank
you bye
thanks evelina
well colors orchestra went home to a
hero's welcome they know about kelping
in the war effort and they said they
planned to sell their trophy to raise
money for ukrainian refugees but it was
a close call in the competition wasn't
it sam ryder who represented the uk came
second with his song spaceman it was the
best result the uk has had in 20 years
yeah we've got a history of not getting
many points nil far in fact but sam
actually came top after all the
international judges gave their vote but
the public vote swayed it for ukraine
[Music]
if you want to know more about the war
in ukraine check out our special
editions of fyi on our webpage at first
hot news forward slash fyi
coming up we'll be catching up with
actress yasmina l abd about her new show
and being a teen mental health
ambassador
[Music]
you've probably seen the famous buffer
tv and film awards on your telly but
it's also an organization that supports
the film and tv industry with training
and experiences
yeah and every year they look out for
future talent with their young presenter
competition our very own braid and won
it a couple years back check you out
here braden hello look at me there i
look so young i actually think i was
eight in that photo i mean just look at
that now not only do the competition
winners get to present for bafta
throughout the year but they also get to
do a very special report here at fyi
here's this year's winner samira with
her special report all about british
sign language hi samira
hi guys great to see you
so this year the young presenter bafta
kids competition was all about
expressing yourself so i chose to
express myself through sign language
hello my name is samira
ikbar i'm here today with my deaths with
my deaf sister
and let's get straight into it so how
did you learn about sign language
um i learned about sign language from my
parents my auntie and my uncle who are
also all deaf
i love sign language because even though
my family can lip read sign language is
so much easier to understand
i was so happy to find out that i had
won the young presenter competition and
i've already got to do some pretty
amazing things like i got to interview
the one and only footballer jesse
lingard and i got to teach him some sign
language as well
[Music]
there you've got it you're such a quick
learner and for my special report for
fyi i get to do something which is
really close to my heart
i am meeting a bunch of students who
also won a competition just like me they
came first in the amazon longitude
explorer prize for developing an app
that can make it easier for all of you
to understand british sign language and
i thought i'd bring my sis along to
check it out
so congratulations guys on your award so
how does it work
so it's a prototype so far because we
haven't developed it fully but this is
what we would like it to look like and
what we want is the ability to translate
from speech to british sign language and
vice versa so for example if i spoke
into this you could have a pre-recorded
video of someone signing the words that
you've just spoken outputted so that
would act as a translator whoa that's so
cool
very cool we also as i mentioned want to
translate from sign language into text
so what we've done so far is if you put
your hand in front
as you can see as you wave your hand or
you make signs in front of the camera
the computer is able to capture the
positions of your hands and so we would
use artificial intelligence to in real
time translate that from british sign
language into text or audio depending on
the output you wanted ruby this is so
cool have a look go and try it try it
my name is ruby
this is so cool do you think it'll be
useful in everyday life definitely
especially at restaurants or cinemas
when lots of deaf people get
miscommunication with other people oh my
gosh restaurants do you remember when
dad ordered a salad but they gave him
bolognese
[Applause]
so what made you come up with this idea
it was kind of based on personal
interactions with people from the deaf
community and learning just how unfairly
challenging it can be and so we thought
maybe this would be a nice opportunity
to try um make something useful so what
advice would you give to other people
like us who want to get into inventing i
think tech skills are the most important
skills you can really have and develop
at the moment so getting into coding and
stuff so congratulations again guys it
was so amazing to finally meet you and i
cannot wait for your app to go live
great report thanks samira now here on
fyi we like to get our heads around some
of the big issues that affect us such as
why is racism still a problem this month
marks two years since the killing of the
black american george floyd by a white
police officer it sparked the worldwide
black lives matter protest against
racism but why does it seem that those
protests have led to little change when
it comes to tackling racism don't get it
i've been investigating
these days we should be able to take it
for granted that whatever our skin color
and whatever our culture background we
should all be treated the same and given
the same opportunities
but it hasn't always been that way
to see how things used to be i'm gonna
need our time machine
i'm setting it for 1776
the year when america declared its
independence from britain
despite america's declaration of
independence saying all men are created
equal
this was the height of slavery
black people were taken by force from
africa to work on plantations in the
caribbean and the americas harvesting
sugar tobacco and cotton
it was a cruel business and while white
slave owners quickly got rich
millions of africans were killed because
of the harsh conditions both on the
slave ships and on the plantations
in those days africans were seen as not
as good as white people
and even though britain banned slavery
in most of its colonies from 1834
slavery continued in some american
states for many years to come
one of the turning points came during
the two world wars
when white soldiers fought alongside
black and asian men to defeat germany
and its allies
finally they were equals
one of those men was war hero walter
tull the grandson of a slave who quit
his career as a footballer to become
britain's first black army officer
after the wars britain needed extra
workers to help rebuild our shattered
country
hundreds of young men from islands in
the caribbean signed up to help and
sailed to the uk on a ship called the
empire windrush
there were also new workers arriving
from south asia
but they didn't get the warm welcome
they expected
their children were bullied at school
just because of the colour of their skin
and some landlords wouldn't let them
rent their houses
but slowly things were starting to
change
increasing numbers of people were
heading to the uk to make it their home
and over in america there was a campaign
for equal rights led by this man martin
luther king he had a dream that one day
black people would be treated as equals
and 45 years later barack obama was
elected as the president
it doesn't matter whether you're black
or white or hispanic or asian or native
american or young or old or rich or poor
able disabled gay or straight you can
make it here in
america if you're willing to try
black and asian people have risen to
important positions in the uk as well
one example is marvin reece who in 2016
became the first man of black african
heritage to be elected as mayor of a
major european city
hi marvin hey how are you doing
so do you think barack obama changed
things for other black and asian people
without question he opened the doors for
people who look like me who look like
him to hold positions of high office and
whole obama family actually i'd say
michelle obama as well are real
inspirations just the dignity you know
the intelligence the competence the
credibility and actually the similarity
of backgrounds as well uh just in terms
of growing up with that much money all
those are were really inspiring to me
you know as i was thinking about what i
was going to do with my life and then
taking initial steps into running for
mayor of bristol
back in 1976 a new law called the race
relations act made it illegal to treat
people unfairly because of their race
it was an attempt to stop people being
singled out and treated badly because of
the colour of their skin
but by the 1980s there were still
problems with riots in cities like
bristol london birmingham and liverpool
people from ethnic minorities were angry
about poor living conditions and the way
that they were being treated
particularly by the police
even in recent times the police have
faced criticism for the unfair way
they've treated black people
both in the uk and in america in one of
the most famous cases a black man called
george floyd was murdered by a white
police officer on the streets of
minneapolis in america it led to black
lives matter protests all over the world
including in bristol where a statue of
the slave trader edward colston was
pulled down and thrown into the harbour
even though racism is still something we
need to stamp out these days there are
so many people to inspire us we've got
sporting superstars glastonbury
headliners oscar winners and business
leaders
every day they remind us that with hard
work and determination we can achieve
anything
the more i don't get it explainers on
big issues like food poverty bullying
and law in ukraine just head to our
webpage first dot news board slash fyi
so we're now joined by actress yazmina l
abd hello thank you so much for joining
us thank you for having me i mean it's a
pleasure so you've been acting since you
were so young but what made you want to
be an actress
um i mean i've always loved the
performing arts in general i went to
performing arts school
but i was always put in ballet class uh
choir all of that so you know everything
led to next so i started doing
commercials then short films and series
and movies so in your show theodosia you
play the egyptian princess sofia what do
you to the character
um i mean for one she was she's an
egyptian princess
and i am egyptian so i think in terms of
representation that was something very
exciting for me
and for the new generation i think it
was important for them to see that on tv
because growing up i didn't see anyone
that looked like me on tv so obviously
girls back home really loved the show so
that was definitely something that made
me super happy the magic is in the room
well of course it is
don't let it touch you
i thought these necklaces were meant to
keep us safe
[Applause]
[Music]
sophia put it on now please not while
there is a fashionable bone in my body
there is no way
and as well as acting you're also an
ambassador for a mental health charity
now how important do you think it is for
us to look after our mental health and i
think it's super important to talk about
it's something you know you struggle
with especially at this age you're
trying to figure out who you are and
what you want to do
and that's never an easy time have you
ever struggled with your mental health
you mean especially with all that
pressure of being a young actress i mean
it's a different it's a difficult
business to be in a normal teenager
could make mistakes and try again but
once you know everyone is looking at you
and focusing on what you're doing you
kind of have this pressure on you to
always be great and smiley and all of
that but i think writing things down
helps me a lot and also just taking the
time to relax self-care is very very
important so i think that's the advice i
would give well i'm sure a lot of people
watching this now will take a lot of
that advice on board
i'm sure they will so thank you so much
for joining us it's been lovely thank
you thank you very much thank you well
that's it from us and if you want to
catch more fyi then just head to our
webpage see you next time
[Music]